Catherine is with us in Fresno
California hi Catherine how are you hi
Dave how are you one question for you
I'm trying to decide what to do with
this truck I'm on baby step number two I
was divorced last year in April and my
ex-husband was supposed to pay off the
truck after six months he decided to
stop paying because the truck is solely
in my name so I have been paying the
truck things on for the last five months
and surviving I don't physically on the
truck in California is still in Indiana
where we were married my brother's
trying to assist me and selling the
truck and we haven't been able to sell
the truck that's what needs to happen
what do you owe on it 21,000 okay what's
it on the market for well Kelly Blue
Book showed that I should be able to get
23 or 24 thousand for it
so I've lured it now to 21,000 you know
absolutely what's your income okay yeah
I mean the answer sell the truck even if
you sell it and I'll loss and write a
check to get rid of it okay so dad what
do you owe
who do you owe the money to Capital One
I am no crap okay you know they're gonna
be no help so I mean you can even borrow
you know if you had to borrow 2,000
bucks or something to get it in write a
check you know it's my patient 19 for it
and you get rid of it that's you know
get rid of the truck it's in Indiana
your brother has possession of it your
ex does not yeah he's the one trying to
help me so it is the market what was he
in a large enough city to solid $21,000
truck or is he out in the middle of
nowhere he wanted to lay down on the
college campus and he has it advertised
family on the college internet site
Craigslist I've had a couple cameras
that have tried but ya know Cosmo
colleges buying a 21,000 our truck no so
I mean we don't live in the area don't
go Craigslist is more
answer than anything else and just wear
Craigslist out with that and and let's
just keep pushing on how long have you
had it on the market November and it's
been really cold and snowing there too
they have really bad weather so it makes
it tougher to move it yeah I guess the
other question is what is Sully's your
what it's sell easier in Fresno
that was my question should I just try
to go get the truck and down here in
California which is probably a better
market for for trucks yeah
when Fresno is a great market for truck
so you know and it's a bigger market
than what we're talking about yeah you
know if it's been since November you
know set a deadline that goes by X date
you know I don't know middle of March if
it hasn't sold I'm gonna go get it yeah
I'm studying for the bar name right now
so I'm really trying to yeah until I
finished my exam these are on you take
the bar in July okay well that's okay if
you can pay the payment though then I
can and then after I take the bar on
them I'll have more income but for now I
got you I guess I could achieve and
chills Alaia don't get the truck it was
either tell your brother to give him you
know you give him a couple hundred bucks
if he'll drive it out there and you
flying back oh that would be nice
something like that yeah you think
you're doing your own baby step to call
Dave oh great idea yeah this is all
about getting rid of that dad and
getting that burden off of you because
it's a $500 payment in it no $700 penis
oh that capital one you got sub primed
oh you got hammered the truck in tech
and we brought the truck in tech yeah
bad credit it's really is really his
truck it's a wasn't even my truck no
it's your truck it's in your name I know
here's the thing the divorce decree said
he's supposed to pay the bill right yes
that's correct
has your attorney taken him back to
court for being in contempt of the
divorce decree no we haven't done that
yeah I was going to wait because he had
until April to I knew the worst you free
to get the truck
solely financed in his name how come so
it's by April he has not done it and we
will file for future yeah I would do
that as well because I'm assuming he has
money he's just being contrary
yes very contrary yeah judges have a way
of dealing with contrary axes with a
judge on a contempt order in Indiana I'm
just telling you it's not a good it's
not going to be a good day for this old
boy so yeah somebody ought to call him
and tell him like your attorney that
you're getting rid knock him in the next
week and he needs to get himself
motivated okay have your attorney call
his attorney and say we're getting ready
jack Bubba up and we just want to let
you know for we Jack Bubba okay not 9
region let's just get every point we can
pushing on this thing and maybe you get
his soul maybe we jack him up maybe he
gets it refinanced into his name that'd
be awesomeness right there maybe you
take it to California if nothing happens
and you just decide you're gonna give up
you're going to be a little tough to put
your contempt order if that trucks in
California though so you probably better
wait if you're gonna go that route till
you get that figured out it'll be tough
to push a contempt order where he's
supposed to refinance a truck and get it
into his name if the truck is in
California he's in Michigan and a
divorce was in Michigan
oh my goodness contended by the minute
he did that purposely he moved to
Michigan so the divorce will not be in
Indiana and then ok well yeah we'll
still will still go that route then but
I would okay you know if that's active
and looking like that might be you're
out I believe the trucks sit until you
know about that part of it okay I don't
want to have to move the truck for to
California and then turn I move it back
to Michigan okay you know if he stepped
up as a result of being smacked with a
contempt order and decided he was
getting then you got to deliver the
truck back right that's gonna get really
inconvenient Emillio you're studying for
the bar so leave the truck in Indiana
till you figure out what's happening
with that contempt order
meantime continued to try to sell it and
meantime have his attorney have your
attorney called his attorney and let him
know we're getting ready Jack him
because he needs to be jacked he's not
playing and you don't mess with a
divorce decree you don't mess with a
contempt order with a judge that's just
a bad idea it will bring pain and
problems to your life not dealing with
something just because you're contrary
is a bad plan
hey thank you for calling in you'll get
through this you'll get it turned around
I'm sorry you're going through it but
that's that's what I would do lay out my
strategy three or four different ways I
can go and in what order I'm going to
attack those moving the truck to
California would be the last one on the
list and so it might be summer before I
did that but good question
thank you for joining us Wow
Wow Wow Wow this is the Dave Ramsey show